of course there's going to be more
coming uh down the track but don't
forget this is a huge amount that we're
spending
on top of the 14 billion that we spent
as soon as we came in to increase
the funding for for primary school
children for for secondary school to
make sure that every teacher started on
a
starting salary of thirty thousand
pounds what we're now doing
is uh the biggest tutoring program
anywhere in the world there's no
question that
um many kids are incredibly resilient
they've bounced back very well from the
pandemic but a lot of them also
need help to catch up to make good the
loss of learning that's taken place
during the pandemic now all the evidence
shows the best way to do that
is to focus on the individual pupil the
individual
child as much as as you can and so
that's why
we're we're going for tutoring in this
in this massive way
and we're going to be supplying uh
15 weekly sessions
which is we think good for
three to five months of attainment for a
uh for a pupil
and what it should do is
give the funds to the to the schools
obviously to to buy in the
uh the tutoring to support tutoring
networks sport tutoring clubs
support tutors uh people to come in and
uh and do it
uh but but also to give parents
the confidence that their child
is going to get particular attention
to help them catch up but also
to find potential in kids that
you know may be missed in in the back of
the classroom so i think tutoring can
make
a huge huge difference but also
supporting
uh putting a lot of money now extra
money into
teaching and supporting teachers as well
great schools are the different great
school of the not so great school is
all about the teachers and the
leadership uh and the imagination
that they show and what we want to do is
support teachers who may be brilliant
teachers but who maybe now need to make
a move to
being say head of sixth form or or even
head of the school we want to support
them
uh give them the the extra uh grounding
that they need
to make that make that change as well so
it's a big package for tutoring
uh it's a huge packet for tutoring it's
a big package for for teaching
and uh hopefully there'll be more to
come last week you said you could see
nothing in the data to indicate that the
next stage of opening up could not
happen on june the 21st
is that still the case i can see nothing
uh in the data
at the moment that means we can't go
ahead with
step four or the the opening on june the
21st but
we've got to be so cautious because
there's no question
the ons data of infection rates
is showing an increase we always
knew that was going to happen don't
forget we always said that
the unlocking steps that we've taken
would lead to increases in
infection what we need to work out
is to what extent the vaccination
program
has protected enough of us particularly
the elderly and vulnerable
against a new surge and
there i'm afraid the data is just still
ambiguous and so every day we're having
long sessions
we're interrogating all the the the data
we're looking at all the various models
and the best the scientists can can say
at the moment
and in their guidance to us is that we
just need to give it
a little bit longer i'm i'm sorry that's
frustrating for people
i know that people i want a clear answer
uh about the way ahead for june 21st but
the moment we just got to wait
a little bit longer the travel industry
and holiday makers will be looking
forward to
what is said tomorrow about
international travel restrictions
can you give anyone any hope that there
might be more countries added to the
green list
you've got to wait and see what the uh
what the the joint biosecurity center
say and what the recommendations are
about
about travel we're gonna try and be uh
trying to allow people to
to travel as as i know that they many
people want to but we've got to be
cautious and we've got to continue to
put countries
uh on the on the red list uh on the
ambulance
uh when that is necessary and we will
have i want you
to know we will have no hesitation in
moving countries
from the green list to the ambulance to
the red list
if we have to do so the priority
is to continue the vaccine roll out to
protect the people
of this country and you know the key
thing i want to get over to everybody
today is
looking at the one thing is clear from
the data two vaccines
really are helpful in protecting you
and your family against the virus so
you know get your second jab finally
many people enjoyed the bank holiday
weekend but i suspect you had a slightly
bigger weekend than most what can you
tell us about your big day
i'm getting on thank you very much carl
i'm getting on with
uh with making sure we can uh
continue the vaccine roll out uh
continue with our program for
educational
uh bounce back and the tutoring
revolution that's what we're getting
with today
well